here is whoopee once again who has no
idea what she's talking about going off
on Ben Shapiro because he's critical of
the Barbie movie
I find it upsetting when material is
based on children's IP Market it's
little girls actually ends up being
angry feminist claptrap that alienates
men from women undermines basic human
values and promotes falsehood all at the
same time wow wow it's a movie
it's a movie about a doll
I I thought y'all would be happy she has
no genitalia so there's no sex involved
Ken has no genitalia so he can't be it's
a doll movie
and you know who I
the kids
know it's colorful and it's Barbie they
haven't lived through what the adults
have lived through so when they're
seeing this movie that's not how they're
looking at it the kids are looking at it
as a Barbie movie you guys I want you
all to tell your daughters why you're
not taking them to see the Barbie I want
you to explain to them what's wrong with
Barbie now look
I love my bar
the dog movie guys that's I'm shocked
that that's what's freaking you out
these days all right first off those
shoes are what's freaking me out but
putting that aside for a second
um they are such deeply if you can be a
deeply shallow thinker that's what these
people are it's not just a doll movie if
you listen to any of the people that
made the movie they're telling you that
they're putting political and cultural
messages in there Brock God bless him he
saw a Barbie he went out there on your
own volition you just he was excited to
see Barbie I sent him out there to find
I send him it's like sending a guy out
to war to find out what's going on in
the real world I'm not gonna do it he
comes back and he reports back to me
when she's saying oh it's just it is
it's just a doll movie it has nothing to
do in the movie according to Brock then
I trust this guy okay uh he says that a
middle schooler in the movie calls
Barbie a fascist so it doesn't even
matter what that's specifically about in
the movie the point is it's not just a
doll movie about a doll with no genitals
they are pushing we played some of the
the song uh yeah yesterday about it
right we played it at the top of the
show in the cold open like they are
trying to do something by the way as I
said yesterday
they can create whatever the hell they
want to create we can react to it I
would prefer that people just build new
things instead of destroying old things
but that's not really what this is about
what this really is about is that the
machine now is viewing remember remember
it was literally over a year ago
remember that week
where everybody on CNN including several
people who have been fired like Don
Lemon and Brian stelter remember with
that whole week where they kept saying
Joe Rogan is a racist because he said
the n-word several times and shouldn't
Spotify do something about Joe Rogan and
I kept saying it has nothing to do with
them thinking he's a racist nobody in
their right mind thinks Joe Rogan's a
racist what CNN did not want because
it's part of the machine is that an
independent guy sitting in Austin Texas
who's due in Ayahuasca hanging out with
all this eclectic group of people was
making more sense and getting more
viewers than them so they were trying to
take out the competition I also want to
say one other thing man I'm fired up
today let me say one other thing on this
and then I have a whole bunch of other
things to say so it's not really one
other thing if I just say one more thing
and then we're ending the show
um when she says uh well I said the
thing about it's just a movie but she
says it's just the doll it's just the
doll and why are we getting worked up
over this lady uh you guys were just
screaming and ranting and raving over
just a song Yesterday just Jason Aldean
right he he's a racist everyone involved
is a racist
[Music]